[Music]
gail is going to start us off in
jacksonville florida hi gail how are you
hey guys i'm great and it's an honor to
speak with you
you too what's up in your world um
i have a question i'm on baby step four
and we me and my husband are ready to
invest unfortunately we haven't invested
up until now and
i'm 57 and he's 59. we can invest
eleven hundred dollars a month um and
i'm wondering
should i still invest in the four mutual
funds that you suggest at my
age or should i be more conservative at
my age
i'm 60 and i do i invest in four types
my 401k looks exactly like i recommend
i don't recommend um and let me tell you
why i don't recommend
stuff for people to do that i don't do
and the reason that the reason i am
continuing to do it and i'm going to
recommend you continue to do it at our
advanced stage what and so
uh but but uh anyway
statistically if you make it to 60 or 65
years old
you have a very high likelihood of
making it into your 90s
the average death age of a male in
america today
is 72 for a female 74.
okay but that includes infant mortality
teenage death and so on
once you make it unless you've got
health problems into your 60s you have a
very high likelihood of another 20 25 30
years
of needing to invest and so over the
scope of not
five years but over the scope of 25
years
what is the best investment mix and
all the data that we have indicates it's
those four types of mutual funds
and that's why i personally do it that
way and can
what advanced age are you uh well dave i
am at the uh
mature age of 46. 46 okay that's your
advanced stage
46 you're doing the four types as well
that's right i do it exactly the way
you tell us to do it because you've got
a track record
i like to look at track records i like
to see the score yeah
how did how did it work out yeah how did
it work out so that's the thing gail
there
what you're running into if you've dealt
with someone that's not a smart investor
pro
in the investment world um there's a
methodology
that the investment world has all
decided that they all believe
um like some like a whole bunch of
people believe something about covet the
whole bunch of people don't that kind of
thing
um and it's just they just decided that
you were all going to die
at around 67 and so they move all of
your investments to conservative
investments in your 60s and uh to me
that's stupid because you're not going
to outpace inflation but i don't do
anything the way anyone else does it i
do it i look at what works and
me following the crowd is not on my list
of things to do
you know andy anders talked about that
in his book
can because it works with career stuff
and it works with investing stuff it
works with get out of debt stuff it
works with almost anything
if you want to um study
the competition his book but deep into
the pool that's what it's called his
latest book
and he came talk to us about it he's a
friend of ours and he said if you want
to beat the competition
study the competition and do what their
best practices are
a little bit better and you'll be three
percent better
but if you want a 40 percent better
result than the competition you have to
do perpendicular opposite of what
they're doing
yeah and it works in any area of life
you know if it's parenting and your
marriage
you know your money uh in your work uh
if you're a small business owner
you know if you're a marketer if you're
social media you know whatever it is
you're gonna have to do your homework
and then decide
okay what's working why is it working
how will i do it
and i think he's absolutely right and
and i think the fact that you've been
courageous enough to say all right let's
if this is the conventional wisdom
why is it the conventional wisdom i
think you start with that you started
going well why is everybody saying it
this way
and at that point you have to have the
courage to use your common sense
and just dig critical thinking skills